今日は vr アーティストの関口愛美です
vr バーチャルリアリティの空間の中に立体の絵を描いています
といっても言葉で伝えても何も当たらないと思いますので
今日はまず実際にライブペイントをしてそれがどんなものかご覧いただきたいと思い
ます
もちろんペット x が私は自分のパフォーマンスの場だとは思ってませんですが
vr アートという新しいジャンル自体が皆さんにとって新しいアイディアや
インスピレーションにつながるものだと私は思っています
なので今日はぜひご紹介させてください
私が vr の空間のなかで見えている司会をモリターに投影しています
それでは
始めていきたいとおもいます
音楽お願いします
[音楽]
[拍手]
wh
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
erotica
beepor
[拍手]
[音楽]
ppap
[拍手]
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
[拍手]
どうもありがとうございます a
[音楽]
ems ていた
はユニーユニティー seaser の空間の中に1体の絵を画くパフォーマンスをし
たりこういった後政策を国内や海外でやらせていただいております
私がこういった新しいジャンルの仕事をしていけるようになったのはもちろんたくさん
の方々のおかげなんですが
主に
sns による発疹がきっかけになりました
ここからも少し vr を使っていきます
また私の視点に砂糖を戻します
私のような仕事にはとってもこの
発信していくということが有効でした vr アートは
空間の中に立体を描いていける
魔法のようなツールですそして
360度別の空間をつくっていくことができる
そしてさらにそこに人が入れるなんて楽しいんだろうと思い私はその様子をこう画像に
撮ったり
動画に録画して sns にアップしました
それが海外や国内からそれをきっかけに依頼を頂いたりして活動できるようになりまし
た
やりたいことがあるという方にはぜひこの発信するということをお勧めしたいです
ですが
まだ自分は未熟だから
まだちょっと人前に出すのは自信がない
そういったネガティブな部分がある人にこそ私は発信することをすすめたいです
まず私自身がすごくそうでしたもう何をやっても才能がなくて点数もなくてどこに行っ
て何をやっても一番足手まといで
ばかりするされていることとかはもう日常茶飯時でした
それでもなのにやりたいんです
自分が作ったものを自分のパフォーマンスで誰かが楽しんでくれるっていう事が私の
生きがいだったんですね
なんか初めて市が入っていうものを感じられたんです
市が入ってなったらずっとやっていきたいずっとやるためには仕事にしてより多くの
時間向き合いたい
仕事にするためにはやっぱり知ってもらわなきゃいけないのでそこで発信です
なんかすごく緊張しますねこんないやまあすごい緊張しちゃうねぇまぁそんな
発信なんですけどやっぱり最初のうちは
高
なんか知っしていくの
どうしよハートでネットにも上がらないいやだあああ
恥ずかしいますよ
ありがとうございます
えっ
自分の
やってることを
何お土産だけどもう
せません
a と
そ
やっぱりそのじゃまだ自分が自信がない納得いってないって言ってもその
じゃあ納得いったものが出来上がってからそれが口コミで広がっていく取材が来る
そうして広まっていくのを待ってるって言うのは
今自分から少しずつも発信できることがあるなら
するっていうのは当然のことだと思います
でもそうなったときにやっぱりまだ自分は納得いかないっていうまだ自信がないって
いうのが邪魔するんですけど
じゃあ何か一納得ができるんだろう
納得してから出そうと思ったらずっとできないんですよね
1個出来上がったあーでもこれ
1回書き直したらもうちょっと良くなるのにな
とか思ってるといつまでも納得できないんですよね
じゃあ
そんなに悠長なこと言ってていいのかこっちは才能ないんですよ
その
そうこうしてる間に
どんどん他の人たちが先に進んでいく
まあ今日大人の方多いからご経験もあると思いますけど
恩返ししたいなって思ってた人はなくなって行っちゃったりするん
そんなにのんびりしてられない
よしじゃあ発信していこう
私もそんなことを言いながらた衣装で来なかったんです
まぁこんなのまだまだしたんだしたらバカにされちゃうかなと思ってたのお友達んだっ
け
画像を見てたんですねそしたらその子がやこんなの見たことないしだした方がいいよっ
て言ってくれて出してみたんです
思ってた以上の反響がありました
ツイッターに載せたんですけど1日で何万リツイートもされて
申す顔も知らない大きな企業の海外の方が問い合わせをして来てくれたり
取材の依頼も来ました
逆に自分がこれ面白いそっと思って発信したものがあんまりリアクションが薄かったり
っていう思わぬ反響っていうのもありました
で私ここで思ったんですあの発信してつことってこの拡散していくことがすごく大きな
メリットではあるんですけど
発信したことでこの帰ってきた反応
これってすごい価値があるものじゃないかなって思って
今は本当に情報の足あふれた社会で検索したり調べればいろんなことが手に入ります
でもこの自分が発信したことによって帰ってくるフィードバッグ
これって
探したりお金で買ったりできない自分ならではの自分にとって役に立つ情報なんですよ
ね
私の場合 vr の良さが同意したら伝わるか
どんな人がどういう反応をしてくれるか
で後 vr で伝えるんじゃなくてスマートフォンとかパソコンでみた動画そうだっ
たらどういう風に伝えるとみんなのリアクションが返ってくるのか
っていうすごく学びが大きかったです
これ同じ時間一人で地道に努力するよりも発信し続けた方がずっとを得られるものが
多いなって思ったんです
じゃあ私なんかはそっちを選ばなきゃと思って
もうそこからどんなに恥ずかしいな失敗しちゃったなって思ったものも出していくよう
にしました
ほんとそんなことしたくないんです
アーティストってミステリアスでかっこいいほうがいいじゃないですか
本当に私もそうしたかった
それに本来の日本の美徳としてはやっぱり陰で努力をするべきだなとも思います
でも自分がカッコ悪く見えても最終的に作品がより良くなる方法を撮りたいって思った
んです
そして
こんなやだもうこんなてと見ただけないほんとやだ
やだよ
[音楽]
8 f
そうここでね私は発信して確保見つけるわけですよ覚悟を身につけるわけで覚悟を決め
たところでそれでもまだ発信することに躊躇する次の壁って
誹謗中傷悪口ですよね
でやっぱりその発信することに戸惑う方はそこが気になる人多いと思います
でも足を引っ張ることに時間を使える人間ですよ
そんな人の言葉私は聞かなくていいと思うもし自分が何かよっぽど悪いことしちゃった
ならもうそれはちょっと自業自得なんですけど
こっちが発信する人がどんな思いでどんな風にそこにいるかそれを創造のせずに傷つけ
られる人の言葉を
私は人生で1 b も大きく必要はないと思ってます
せませんあの女がタイマー終わってないといけません
家に持ちついていく必要ないと思うんですよねねっ
ありがとうございます一問一曲必要なんてなくていい
また質問持ち何やってもいいかな
hey
家魅力行く必要なくて
まあそもそもですねあのもっともっと
そんなことが気にならなくなるぐらい発信することにはメリットがあるんですよ
でっ
ここからはですねそのメリットを得ていくためには
という方もう
そのメリットを得ていくためには
この
上っ面の言葉頑張りますこれだけでは全くダメなんですよね
意味がない
寝てるかな
見てますすいませんありがとうございます a そして大事なのは進捗と継続
進捗情報を共有する今こんなことやってるこんなことをやりたいと思ってる
逆に今行き詰まっているちょっとテッドで失敗しちゃって私大変っっ
いう現状ね現状ぞもうまさにさっきを現場を私がこうやって報告してるからこそみんな
拍手してくれたりガンバレって言ってくれる
これがねほんとにまさにねー
応援とね支えにつながってくるんですよ
逆に私が今を伝えなかったら応援したいと思っても何もできないじゃないですか
こうしていくうちにあのたくさんのを支えてくれる方や仲間や先輩
素敵な出会いが重なっていくんですそして継続なんですがこれは
信頼につながっていくんですよね
まあ継続していくという物事を継続するっていう行動自体が信頼にもつながるんですが
ここでは sns の発信を繰り返すことでそれがネット上の数字として溜まっていく
んですどれぐらい発信していたかじゃソルフォロワー数とか
閲覧数とか目に見えるものが溜まっていきます
それネット上でをこのこの作品面白いなと思っても仕事を依頼するっていうのは
特に海外の全く顔も知らない人だったら結構勇気がいることだと思います
そこにネットの数字っていうのは安心材料の一つになるんですよね
ネットの数字を貯めていこうと言うとすごいドライなぁ
言葉皿に聞こえるんですけど私はすごくそれって誠実な行動なんじゃないかなと思って
います
そしてまだ発信をすることでは
を得られる素敵なものが隠れていたりします
ちょっとあ読み込むのに意外と時間がかかっちゃった
まだ
まだ見ぬところに発信には素敵な世界が広がっていたりしますってこうやりたかったん
だな
このね中にね素敵な世界が実は隠れてるよっていうのをやりたかったんですけど
ちょっとね
じゃカメラを停止って
信頼を積み上げて発信を続けていくと今度は発信力が自分に身につくようになります
そうすると今度は自分の絵関わっているプロジェクトや自分の作品を広げていくって
いう行動が自分自身でできるようになります
そしてもっともっと続けて行くとまだ残念ながら私はそこにはイケてる
ないけど発信することで経済効果を生んだり
関わる業界や地域まで活性化させられるような発信力を持っている人もいます
それってすごく何か大きな話かもしれないんですけど
もしそれが持てたら楽しいことをやりながらお客さんが楽しくて
お金を出すスポンサーとかプライアントも楽しくて関わる人みんなハッピーです
a その業界地域もしかしたら思わぬところにもまたハッピー思えるかもしれない
その可能性を秘めてるんですね
これは大それた話かもしれないけど
押しをとってお金が動い動いて何か幸せを見出すんだから大なり小なりその活動をして
いくべきことだと思うんです
そういった大きな可能性そして先ほどお話しした拡散と
を学び出会い
珍來
端によっていろんなものが得られます
えっ
私は今日またすごく素敵な出会いを手に入れました
超本当に私がボロボロの中乗り切れたのは皆さんのおかげです本当にありがとうござい
ます
アーネット見てる方してみますなぁこんな本当に
にえっ
本当にあの私が伝えたかったのは発信によって生まれることがたくさんあるからやり
たいことがある人は小さなことでもいい
近くの身近な人に話してみたり sns に書いてみたりしてそこから何かあなたに
とって小さなきっかけが変化が生まれたら私は幸いです本当にどうもありがとうござい
ました
ます
[拍手]